era esattamente il 20 gennaio del 2013
quando pubblicai which il primo uno dei
primissimi giochi mi sono messo gli
piace come dei primissimi giochi horror
che feci sul mio canale lo fece
esattamente in questa stanza che potete
vedere esattamente quanto il mio armadio
e lo vedete anche in questo video oltre
sette anni fa a distanza di tutti questi
anni è il momento di riprovare poi sono
ritornato mother padre prova a vedere se
sono più performante degli anni scorsi
spero di sì a questo due persone gli
scalini per una serie scalini o mio dio
una finestra valigia era meglio prima
devo riuscire ritrova a capire che non
mi dicono niente di suo amico lecce sta
tizia che non la devi guardare numero 1
che voi scherzate ma so già cosa più di
dieci anni
ok quindi all'inizio quando io che sarà
bellissima cosa quando ho iniziato a
fare i giochi horror non ce n'erano
molti che quelli che noi giocarci anno
tipo 2 o 3 questo slider me ne basta
tipo ce ne fosse altri 12 è questo qua
era uno uno di quelli questo che si
chiama which c'è un cesso permesso
ho trovato la chiave numero 3 che è
cascata nel lavandino ovviamente mia
solita sfiga ps3 sia ci si può anche
abbassare e se fosse la prima che gli
scaffali della cucina dove la modella
non lo trovate assolta perchè a questa
volta per una volta le cascate la chiave
è perché c'è il cuore che batte successo
comunque pensavo stavolta di trovare la
nutella
in questo punto preciso era partito
tutto lo slang di dove la nutella
famiglia e la nutella da questo video
che poi non l'ho mai detto di troppi
video solo che la gente poi centrata
infisser nostro qua troppo vicino mi
batte il cuore senza un apparente motivo
dopo aver non ho capito comunque cosa
devo fare spiegami
chiave più due persone
no schiacciato il tasto sbagliato viso
il gioco parco demonio ha una porta c'è
una portanza e propria finestra o faccio
una chiave dei perfetto non nuovo visto
sono tutto andrà a vedere me stesso di
sette anni fa perché non trovo la chiave
perfetto come mi sono evoluto come
videogiocatore un fenomeno cacchio
sospensione prima prima le sapevo ste
cose
adesso no povero vado io vado avanti più
peggioro meraviglioso è vero quando
dicono che fa vi gira meglio prima
minchia prima ci arriva vagliare le
soluzioni se sono qua quindi c'è una
chiave chi l'aveva vista sono un pirla
chiave numero 2 chiave diversa da
persone va beh chi se ne frega avremo
due salve eccola e lavoro fermati lei
c'è la chiave li è grazie
chiave questo è quello che capita una
macchia ha uguale renderman diverso dal
cuore vela touch mybat chiave uguale
testa diverso da cuore cioè non sorriso
del demonio morto ma che sono cagato
nelle mutande a posto
mi dovresti dare la chiave dov'è andata
sparita favore non ho capito lo ha detto
chiaro che non ho capito niente di
quello che mi ha detto però 18 sabato 18
la zia 26 la zia
eccola qua mi servirebbe la chiave che
hai mi serve la chiave che hai nelle
mani che hai nel poi hai almeno almeno
xvi tav il lavandino o il marchio basta
stai stai a casa tua
ok non mi toccare parte che ciao type
air ma voglio vedere che dietro c'è il
buco non quello che pensi tu questo qua
nel cuore qualcuno ti ha fatto male ti
ha ferito sentimentalmente comunque non
si apre il lavandino mi mila eravano che
lavandino in realtà è tuo
perfetto però farlo senza farmi pagare
di sopra grazie ma quindi la porta qui
si apre che si apre una sega madonna di
dio però ci sono cagato addosso era male
che ho fatto bene il suo gioco e
scherzare no vabbè non si apre di sotto
non si apre di sopra o cambiamo gioco
secondo me c'è una chiave che non sto
vedendo l'avevi cricchetto dovete avere
filiamo questo si può chiudere la porta
lo si è chiuso dentro e cricchetto per
aprire la aprile landino che ne so io le
nasconde gli oggetti si sta a casa
maledetta non si vede nulla finché non
ti avvicini con la con il naso
sull'oggetto non si vede niente non è
colpa mia mamma
ho trovato la chiave dell'opera chiave
numero 3 state bona talebani con i
talebani questa qua di sculaccia tutto
il tempo sta pervertita poi farlo contro
i jazz e tranquillo no non si fa a luca
cosa che c'è qua dentro scusate ma posso
guardare cosa c'è dentro senza che mi
devasti l'anno per favore
c'è un armadio posso aprire le armadio
che c'è scritto qua create by mike inez
va bene quelli di coda mi interessano
relativamente ristorno gioco ancora non
è finito
c'è un'altra chiave che non è la chiave
della testa ti dovresti togliere che in
questa chiave per la chiave rose lander
cioè un altro accesso ai gigli 2 chacin
sta a casa ho trovato la testa e la
testa sua e come cazzo infinito leather
va bene la porta e qua qua sta di qua
miei entra pure brava come ci è finita
la testa non buttate le feste in eccesso
ragazzi si intasa tutto è un casino è
cristo se pure in oc ha posto a posto
perfetto posso uscire a cosa fai mi apre
a parma cosa stiamo piano di sopra che
c'è il bancone qua mi scusi c'è la porta
di sotto che la porta del cuore quella
non lavoriamo la porzione del cuore se
ma tipo maria de filippi
allora persona più chiave vuole porta
aperta diverso da chiave più due persone
no no no no a prituri tua pittura per
tutto il tuo partito se chiuso la porta
si comporta qui scherzato scherzo no no
no no no no cucini chi tu uccidi di te
aiaf orco demonio che male ai a madonna
ecco cosa voleva dire quella roba lì
ma brutta pezzente fallo ancora dai se
il coraggio che ha avuto coraggio ma
marcelo passi dalla pasta porco demonio
canzoni titanico contrattaccato in
questo momento che sta sentendo comunque
un gioco serli friendly buonuscita prego
torna quando vuoi
adesso iniziamo a fare tutti i video dai
dai dai sette anni fa fino ad oggi li
faccio tutti i video ogni giorno
riproduttivi dove chi fantastico era era
veramente figo allora allora non c'era
di tag d oro novati sessisti sette anni
per essere un horror dei tempi porca
vacca se fatto bene non ho mai capito se
c'è un altro finale robe con la porta
col cuore punto però veramente figo
comunque spero che vi sia piaciuto sette
anni fa è ritornato niente
nella stessa stanza visto regionale a
tutti i giochi vecchi stanze non so che
mi ascolta in qualche modo mi sta dando
del pirla minchia poi giochi nuovi lo so
però che gli sia piaciuto ragazzi come
seguito e mi piace street era chiusa
dalla campanellina prima della giornata
sono i video e noi come sempre ci
viviamo a robusti ovito bella ragazza
[Musica]